liftoff on Apollo 11 bad quality they
think Oh Oh clamp it 50 years ago the
Olin Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin became
the first humans to ever land on the
moon one small step for man one giant
leap for mankind that whole thing
astronauts also brought back the first
samples of the moon they brought back
rocks and soil from the lunar surface
having Apollo samples here on the ground
where we can study them change the
entire field of planetary science it's
revealed stuff not only about the moon
but about how other planetary surfaces
change and evolve and we continue to
study them today they are still
revealing secrets about the moon itself
and the rest of the solar system
NASA keeps most of those samples at the
NASA Johnson Space Center in Houston in
a secure pristine clean room I got to go
visit
[Music]
so I showed up at the lab and I met
Charisse Kreischer what I do is I
prepare apollo moonrocks samples for our
scientists out in the community so that
they can do research they keep all the
rocks in the cleanroom and for the lucky
people who get to go in there the price
of admission is putting on this crazy
suit that's supposed to keep all of your
human stuff from getting anywhere near
the rocks the last step was an air
shower please watch your step it
actually felt more like a light breeze
[Music]
[Applause]
this moon rocks out there there are a
bunch of clean rooms here at NASA
Johnson but this one is called the lunar
pristine samples lab that's because the
moon rocks stored here have not been
exposed to earth air at all since they
arrived back on earth in the 60s and 70s
there you have a lot of water in the air
and you have a lot of oxygen in the air
and as soon as a rock is exposed to the
Earth's surface it gets attacked by
those two things and the minerals inside
those rocks start to change immediately
the pristine rocks are kept in these
special cabinets that are filled with
pure nitrogen instead of earth air and
they have a higher pressure on the
inside than the outside so if air ever
escapes it comes out and away from the
rocks instead of things going in to
potentially contaminate the rocks
it feels like it's hugging my arm is
really a pain yes that's the pressure
yes all right cool
[Music]
only three materials can come into
contact with these rocks they're
aluminum Teflon and stainless steel so
first you have your gloves in your bunny
suit then you have the gloves that let
you reach into the cabinet and if you
want to pick up a sample directly you
have to put on Teflon gloves on top of
that so what the lunar sample processors
do in this room is they prepare rocks to
send out to researchers who can then
study them to do that they have to break
off little chips of the rocks sometimes
they use buzz saws sometimes they use a
hammer and a chisel sometimes they just
scoop up some soil and weigh it and then
they can package it up and send it off
into the world I used to work in a lab
where we worked with pictures of Mars
from the Mars rovers Spirit and
Opportunity my job was to process
pictures of dirt as they were sent back
to earth and all I wanted was to scoop
up some of that Mars dirt and just let
it run through my fingers I figured this
was the closest I could get to actually
touching some extraterrestrial space
dirt am I allowed to reach in and hold
the finger in yarmulkes three knots we
can matter
unfortunately no one is allowed to touch
the moon rocks in the pristine lab
that's the whole point of the pristine
lab but I think it's a hold a sample
that was encased in this acrylic trophy
which was pretty darn good this is a
moon rock in my hand when the processors
are ready to send a sample out to a
researcher they pack them up really
carefully and then they just ship them
out through the regular mail they don't
label it this is a moon rock or anything
they don't label them fragile and they
don't even insure them because what
would you insure it for they're
priceless when samples come back
researchers mail them back and they're
no longer pristine because they've been
outside
nitrogen cabinets those rocks are mostly
available to use again in other studies
the processors keep very careful track
of everything that has ever happened to
them so that researchers know whether
previous experiments can affect their
current experiments at least a little
bit of every single sample has been
analyzed we have roughly about 80% of
our collection is still considered
pristine we have about about 5% is out
display on display about another 5% is
out to our scientists around the world
and another 15% of each sample is in a
remote storage facility at another NASA
Center center just in case something
happened to this facility and we lost
the samples in this facility one of the
things these rocks have told us is that
the moon probably formed in a giant
impact where the early Earth when it was
still hot molten four and a half billion
years ago collided with another proto
planet that might have been about the
size of Mars the debris from that
collision splashed out into space and
congealed to form the moon at the end of
Apollo 11 when Neil Armstrong was
finishing up the first moonwalk ever he
was packing up the rocks into this
sample box that they were gonna bring
back to earth and he saw that there was
some space left in it and he didn't want
the big rocks to jostle around so he
threw in some scoops of soil to kind of
cushion them
best idea that he could have had because
they ended up bringing back so much
sample that there were a lot of outlying
studies that could be done that wouldn't
have gotten samples otherwise the soils
from Apollo 11 contained these little
white rocks called northa sites these
are not very dense these are really
light rocks and scientists thought that
maybe they had floated to the surface of
an ancient lunar magma ocean
and formed a crust that used to cover
most of the moon over the years
instruments get better new
instrumentation is invented new
techniques come about there are
questions we can answer now
that scientists didn't even know to ask
in the 70s so keeping these samples
pristine will help scientists for the
next 15 years answer questions that we
haven't even thought of today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]